now is the official start with the
podcast turn their name near noon now
we're starting hey what's up everybody
welcome back corridor digital podcast we
are here with Kristian Nick and Jan
hello now most of you guys probably know
Christian and Nick but Jan might be a
fresh face to a couple you guys he's
been on the fringes of the channel for
years ever since we met him back in the
day when he did dubstep guns you might
remember him as the villain from that
yeah that's right that's what we met
yeah in a brick factory in this part
yeah Sean Amon fs100 yeah and Jan Jan is
now a corridor helping us out with node
as well as a couple other things like he
shot the that Ghost Hunters video that
we did Jan is a accomplished DP and
knows his way around a camera or two but
he also knows his way around talking
about some interesting subjects as well
he's joined us on this podcast and I'm a
lover of life what can I say I just love
this big planet we're on and all the
weird crazy yeah so anyways to kick
things off you know it's a classic
prompt but it's simple one pronged all
right so first things first we're gonna
talk about time travel but kind of
establishes the rules because time
travel is all made up and that's when
the problems have you ever watched a
movie about time travel you started
thinking about the logic and being like
well does this make sense
hey guess what it's all made up so when
the filmmaker just comes up with a
[ __ ] reason for why things work it's
just as legitimate as if they don't
anything else yeah yes but so in this in
this hypothetical you're gonna go back
in time okay but from that point forward
life will proceed as normal you know
things are not set in stone it's not
like one of those weird like somehow
you'll trip and fall in the exact same
way that you've always been determined
to fall that will cause the same thing
to happen and he'll carry will still
blow up etc yeah sure so the the future
the future from your point of
you can still change it's just life as
normal so I think your actions can
change the future
in fact in this hypothec all it's almost
it's almost the same thing as if you
just got a letter from the future saying
hey this is what's up and then you can
just act from there so anyways knowing
all this you're gonna go back in time
can you met Hitler as a baby would you
an assassination squad at this point we
are no no no no just you step through a
wormhole suddenly and now you you're
back in time you're in Austria in this
little bedroom Austria where this oh I
am not purposely gone here no you see
this baby and the baby has all the
potentials that any baby has it can be
anything but you know this baby's name
is Adolf Hitler we know it okay so we
know that okay so the baby's the baby is
Adolf Hitler but it's Adolf as a baby
yeah could you take him out would that
be morally wrong because it's a baby and
anything could happen babies are pure
innocent features I mean I mean this is
close to the trolley argument right the
the if you see of a train that's out of
control and it's heading toward five
people but you can pull lever and switch
it toward killing one person as opposed
to five mm-hmm you are more morally just
what makes you more morally just yeah
making the switch or just letting it
play out or like and in this case
shooting baby Hitler or suffocating baby
Hitler or or any number of ways of I
mean it also brings into question you
know nature versus nurture as baby
Hitler evil or is it his circumstances
that kind of formed him and baby
Hitler's definitely the seeds of evil is
it possible for being his father was not
a nice guy
but we have not been we have not stepped
through a wormhole and magically found
ourselves in the moral not dilemma of
just that's not we find ourselves it now
we find ourselves that now is we have
like a five minute window with baby
yeah people start they can what the [ __ ]
is that dude doing with baby so the
question you know in this in this
scenario here does World War two still
happen even if Hitler goes away the
future is as undecided
as anything else it is is right now we
do not know what's gonna happen in our
current future so it's just right back
then you're at that point you're living
in the present and anything could happen
now realistically World War one as World
War One already happened yes we sailor
part in it yeah he fought he was
decorated so then this would be before
world or was it before World War one if
he says before World War one this is
still 1890s I think probably
theoretically anything could happen
the poliana k-- treaties are still in
place what you could do is go to the
british artillery gunner who just missed
hitler on the front line and just tell
him a little bit you are averting us
toward a much less morally complicated
situation the problems that we are faced
with is five minutes of them maybe
hitler fine all right what do you do you
only get five minutes and you're
transported back to the new future no
you have to still live out in the future
there's no going back you're stuck in
that time okay so maybe I don't have
five minutes maybe I I decide to raise
baby Hitler and May
but you have to kidnap that baby out of
the hospital here than kidney I mean
yeah IIIi think even Hitler's mom would
be like I mean giving up Hitler that's
fine
she'd be probably okay his mother would
probably kill you
she was a peasant strong peasant woman
so what do you do you tell him from the
hospital and there's this butch German
Austrian peasant mother who's six
children almost all died and Hitler is
her one child who's actually survived
from her marriage so it's extra special
to me what do you do Jim oh man I hit a
few neck yeah I knew Nick at abhi I
think there's a bigger question okay
here that we are all just stepping over
which is how obliterated drunk do you
have to get to kidnap or kill a baby
because that's that's a good question
but I think once again we're starting to
dodge around there dancing five minutes
you're right there and you're like my
sweet beyond you might never see him
again until he's you know in charge of a
lot of bad things get those five minutes
what do you do yeah because the facts
are we know if we do nothing he's gonna
grow up to be the Hitler and sure so
right or like as look look and I
understand what I'm about to say is like
stepping into weird morally gray
territory but do you just like cleave
off an arm dude is not going to demand
the command just do you do you what do
you would ya what do ya what do you do
there cuz just smash a photo cool like I
don't know you right Diablo
get a little bit nitty-gritty here do it
do you kill him would that do baby
though cuz do you just do nothing in let
history play out how it plays out
because that's tough yeah yeah I mean
part of the there also is the like
deterministic like you know what what
happens in life happens happen in human
perspective on the value of things is
entirely invented by humans so you know
the universe the universe is impartial
to Hitler personally when I have to
ponder this question and I have pondered
this question many times oh we know I
have to basically way it leads me to an
existential crisis of am i okay with
never have being existing if it saves
all the suffering of all those people of
all those people who were probably not
existing in that timeline so I would
disappear if I if I killed the baby I
would probably just probably I mean so
many events would change right like
America would become the superpower it
is but at the same time like just as
complex is the events unfolding from
killing a baby in Austria and you know I
think you just stepped you're killing a
baby
you're going for the what I'm getting at
is just as complexes it can get from
killing that baby right what could
happen what could not happen I don't
think that World War two necessarily was
all caused because party would still
rise it just wouldn't have as
charismatic leave there there were other
guys involved we're trying to stop the
rising of this charismatic leader who
takes them further than because I mean
yeah cuz I just don't think the Jews
would have been wrapped into it as badly
as they ended up getting wrapped into it
if Hitler wasn't there sure world war
two happen sure a lot about booth but at
least you're able to push the spear a
little bit away for bad community yeah
yeah that's a good point too yeah man
all right oh no man I mean I'm I'm of
the mind of not killing the baby would
you do anything for the baby no no I
would probably go meddle in some other
Affairs that are happening later okay I
wouldn't kill a baby
I might take out step so what you live
the rest of your life just like plotting
the question rad script dude that I get
strapped to the past that is doing his
best to like shift the timeline on the
events that he knew what what I might do
is take the gun and shoot as that
instead okay okay so you think without
Papa Hitler his back goes without a
father figure but maybe doesn't have
some of that early childhood abuse or
you know stuff that may have pushed him
in that direction I think so I think he
might have his mom might have remarried
and two maybe a nicer guy because his
dad was a total a-hole learning World
War two then was it makes him just even
a better leader I mean nature versus
nurture starting to come yeah I think
that's a major question though when you
when you simplify the question of like
are you gonna kill a baby or not then
yeah that's what I'm saying
yaha boom it's the best of both worlds
blind them in one eye or something
that's pretty cool though I badges some
of you would fight you follow somebody
with it but there he knows he's bad a
little more quickly when he has a knife
edge like ooh watch out for that guy
he's like yeah it's like you have an
eyepatch just get like a really hot
spoon and just burn the top of his lip
so he could never grow hair there he's
just this bald bald faced man for the
rest of his life that's our word
[Music]
[Laughter]
somebody with maybe a few lesser limbs
would not be so pedestal yeah no totally
of course but you know they weren't
exactly nice dude like crippled people
back in those days that too they have a
good life being a [ __ ] days and some
like easy affair you know even
wheelchairs or whatever aren't gonna be
has you know but now you have us instead
of killing this baby where we're leading
someone into a life of pain and
suffering
does that I go to sleep fine is that
enough to change I mean yeah I guess
does it change enough events but if he's
not involved in that way because he's
probably gonna grow up a ridiculed
[ __ ] and not really into that
position yeah I mean if if we were to
know that it did change it for sure if
someone's like if you do this it will
change it we can look into the future
too and we can see that it'll change it
yeah like you can hop back in real quick
sleep fine and sleep fine but you know
ok well let's let's open up that
question if you go back and prevent
World War 2 from happening you flip of a
switch
would you knowing that it's gonna change
all events from there on out into a you
know historical event existing I
actually would not because a friend of
mine always says this the devil you know
is better than the devil you don't say
I'd rather the world war 2 we had
stead of like the world war two that
happens in the 60s with nuclear weapons
and eggs you know I think I'm with you
on that one like you know humankind we
sit back and like take this really
universe and this cosmic lens on like
humanity like we have to learn from our
mistakes and like the byproduct of World
War two is hey let's stop having world
wars you know it's all of Europe's like
tensions and weird treaties and fuses
have all been lit and then diffused and
like there's still repercussions from
that that we're dealing with to this day
but like yeah sure no you and things
would not be obviously not be what they
are now I thought World War two but you
know does that historical lesson has
that elevated us now as there's a
culture and like put us in on a path to
success you know to have gotten through
the atomic era without killing ourselves
it's a miracle it's a miracle
thermonuclear war but yeah it's called
like the great filter or like the great
barrier or something like that it's a
thing where as each civilization reaches
the point where they can start venturing
out into space and becoming a cosmic
civilization they also achieve power to
wipe themselves out and the vast
majority of races apparently do you know
theoretically because like you know
futurologists and that was our that's
one of our great filter moments I mean
we're still there don't get me wrong
like at any point it's still wiping out
but like you know we at least got
through the Cuban Missile Crisis and
like the dozens of other encounters I'm
sure between Russia and America we never
and will never hear about the yeah I
think I that was like one of the Russian
like silo guards like all the alarms are
going off saying that like they've lost
contact with Moscow and missiles have
been launched in the right you need to
launch missiles because that's the
protocol and he's like no I'm not gonna
then later on you like you know you
leave the bunker and everything's fine
there were no nukes it's like you made
the right call buddy and then the edits
of a student short film that's how close
we get to Jesus
ducks thermo tote that brings up another
moral question okay let's say you are
the dude in the missile silo and you get
an alert the nuclear bomb has just
landed on new york and let's say it's
this is not like oh maybe it didn't
happen like it happened you know it
happened like this video feed etc and
you have the ability to decide to launch
a nuke back at the enemy would you or
would you back you know what mutually
assured destruction what's what's the
value just wiping out a million people
like why just so we can all be dead like
wait to fire back yeah I mean we all
want to say we wait probably we'll all
say we're gonna wait but if you're in
that circumstance and you've been
trained would you I I just like pushing
buttons oh man Christian I mean to call
yeah I mean if I'm the person making a
decision it's tough I mean it's a lot
there's a lot of emotions in that
decision yeah sure did I lose my family
in the New York blasts or whatever I
mean it's there it's a tough one I mean
if I'd be I mean yeah I'd like to say
I'd wait too and see really kind of
assess whether firing back is the best
idea but I don't know I don't know what
I would do in that situation I mean
truth be told I don't think any of us
would yeah any time I've been in the
most stressful moments of my life I've
never reacted the way that you want it
to right
how badly do you think that guy wanted
to push that button though oh man I'm
sure that must be staring at that button
under a glass case for like synchronized
key thing
[Music]
every day with the maid has to come in
and dust the button and keep it clean I
don't know I probably wouldn't push it
in that situation but who knows man yeah
I mean you're talking about killing
millions of people you know they did to
you first you're still doing that action
you know you're still making that
decision to take out a million more
people sure that's not an easy decision
to have in your factory yeah
you don't know that that's happened to
you first though that's the thing like
if we were sure that that happened then
it would be like alright well I should
probably press this button you don't
know it's difficult okay any more
morally vexing situation do you got
cooking there guys I do have one I have
one license to say this one it's like
suet it's really rough
Mike Deva brought this up he's like this
is a really awful one so maybe we'll cut
this one from the podcast I don't know
you can make a decision afterwards
okay all right all right so you're doing
with the Freaky Friday scenario right
okay your mother and your girlfriend or
significant other or some sort their
minds have switched so now I'll cut in
your and your mom and the person you're
dating okay yeah so the priests to
dating now has your mom's brain oh man
you know there's there's a movie with
them
dude from californication where is no
his daughter and his wife switch minds
are like yes wit mind goes into body and
then sewed the whole movie like yeah
gets into like a horny anyway let's see
I want to know the question okay alright
the only way to revert them Oh musta
have sex with one of them okay which one
do you pick you have your mom's body
with your mom's mind yes yeah I mean
because I was thinking it's it's
obviously I mean it can be a very visual
act but at the same time like you're
saying you can blindfold you can block
that out a lot alcohol
[Laughter]
that in her mind at all she just flipped
back all sudden after the Sun and sorry
for trampling over your introduction of
the subject I just rather kill a Hitler
baby than deal with this to go very
poorly yeah yeah yeah do you think it
creates a whole new timeline or it would
just change the house a good question I
I feel like time is that means whether
or not you subscribe to the parallel
universe thing but I feel like time is
already set everything that's happened
has happened and will happen alright dr.
Manhattan yeah you know it's like yeah I
mean interesting question of free will
right like what do you think I don't
think it means you don't have free will
because I think you're doing with two
different dimensional decisions here if
you can travel through time you're
traveling I mean it's not technically
the force to mention but you're you know
you're traveling through another
dimension space-time you know versus
Free Will exists in a three dimensional
space with a continuous time so it's
like we have free will but I think if
you can be a being that lives where a
times then you can kind of I still think
we need to redefine free will once we
start like this yeah because you start
looking at I am a male trapped in a body
in Southern California at 2020 like that
there are so many variables
me just being before I even make a
decision that and so many chemicals and
a bunch of gross organs and they're all
working in unison let's just avoid all
of that business like because liking is
a programmed thing yeah so anyways I see
enough moral conundrums for one podcast
ended up banger let's change topics for
a second here so Jim for a while you're
studying something called the Chaos
magic and I my pursuits in magical
theory and thinking are constant and
sometimes vexing this doesn't mean that
you're this isn't me that you go like
birthday parties need do you like cuckoo
key tricks and pull like handkerchiefs
out of my mouth no I'm actually not
allowed around birthday parties
no I am NOT an illusionist i I've I've
spent a lot of time studying hermetic
and esoteric magics from ancient periods
the Egyptians and further back I've
studied a lot of Aleister Crowley's work
with the Hermetic order of the Golden
Dawn I've studied a lot of Phil Hines
work with Chaos magic which is a very
very specific kind of magic and it's
it's all like Matt it's all modern it's
all modern philosophies
for alternative people meaning which
it's like the best analogy I ever heard
it uh
the way I ever heard it put was it's
like the secret wallet chain addition so
it's all the same knowledge that's in
the secret it's all the same like you
put yourself forward and like you know
you you put stuff out in the world and
it'll come back to you and all that
stuff you know moms really drive in just
with like a kind of hip edge man it's
got like it's got some nails it'll
scratch can you can you get an example
sure so and Nick real quick I think your
mics out I can't yeah Nick I knew it he
came in with some witty diatribe let's
give him a second yep still can't hear
you and that's the meaning of life there
it is yeah I mean one practices or what
exactly does this mean so Bri look let's
look at chaos magic I myself am more of
a hermetic magic practitioner but chaos
magic is like in in magical terms the
new hip thing it's it's very it's kind
of acknowledging that there are there
there is something to a ritualistic
practice that that we practiced rituals
for so long as a culture that it really
is imbued in us that it it does allow
you to look at situations and and and
open up in ways that not doing rituals
is preventing you from and there are big
rituals we all still do wedding
or any number of practices birthdays are
still kind of in that territory and you
know Brian Greene once argued that you
you have this large part of your brain
that is that needs a sort of religious
figure and if you don't fill it with a
sort of religious figure it will get
filled in with something so if if you
ever talk to someone who disagrees on
politics with you and they are just way
too into it that I would argue that part
of the brain they have started filling
in with that idea of their politician
and I think all politicians look so it
kind of it kind of it doesn't work for
me so I realized if I just let that part
of my mind go anything is going to get
filled in there and suddenly I'm arguing
against you know dumb stuff so why not
fill it in with my own dumb stuff right
with fun dump stuff so I'll give you an
example and this is one of Phil Hines
examples I cannot take credit for this
paddle but let's say you really want a
laptop right and again this is kind of
this kind of shows Phil Hines mindset
because this is exactly his example so
the fact that Phil Hein author and chaos
magician extraordinaire can't afford
laptop but anyway you really want a
laptop so you start to envision and
embody a deity around and and you can
pull from anything you could pull from
from Giddy's that actually exists you
can make up your own you could kind of
bring them in and and and give that
deities some power through some
ritualistic practice and this is where
it gets super deep and this is where I
probably couldn't cover it in one
podcast session and this is where you
need to know way too much but fill it in
with some sort of ritualistic practice
whether whether it's crying or doing
doing that's an actual physical ritual
that you use some doing something to
this deity that you just created to try
to get some fun to try to to try to move
the universe in order to get you a
laptop you have to basically make a
wedge in it and then find a way to
wiggle that wedge and again and that
makes it some sort of real thing that
treat it in once again and I am dude any
chaos magician listening to this is
going to [ __ ] hate me it is at least
the secret right it's like the secret if
you put it out there it'll come back at
you if you want riches you have to say I
want riches right so this is a version
of that it just brings in ritualists
ritualistic practices and unfortunately
a lot of these ancient religions a lot
of these esoteric and like hermetic
religions the Pythagorean all of these
are not only dead religions but we know
nothing about
we know nearly nothing all of it got
burned by big one of the religions you
actually know about of anything that was
before them
so really it's kind of like it's kind of
like the the coloring book of religions
you have an outline and you get to fill
in the rest and dude you get to have a
bunch of tattoos date shoot coffee
chicks it's [ __ ] rad it also again I
I believe a lot of these practices are
very meditative mainly because I do
meditate through most of it there's a
lot of research around meditation
showing its benefits for the mind and
your body and just kind of a your
general mindset but it's also it's it's
like a it's the Tapatio of meditation
because you meditate and you also do
some kooky crap that they used to do I I
got a hold of us some bones mode from a
trip out to Texas with my friend McClure
on
you take bones and throw them into a
pile and meditate and stare at them and
that's called scrying right and you try
to take whatever the shape the bones
have formed you try to take like your
first impression of it and meditate on
that symbol and then later on try to
look up what that symbol man means and
find some association with it now is
this helpful is this a waste of time
does it make me a more interesting
person I don't know but when you take
part in that ritual say say the bone one
for example sure scrying yeah you can do
it with uhm clarity in the moment let's
say so
sometimes I real quick what was a
question Krishna and I'm saying yes so
like so when you take part in that
ritual or whatever what are you getting
out of that are you I mean is it is it
something as simple as the like oh you
might want a laptop in the future and so
you're taking part to get that laptop or
is there something different for you
you're sure it depends it depends on the
rituals it depends on it depends on
exactly what I go into it doing oh I'll
give you a cutesy example that I just
had my lady was traveling from here to
another state so the airport's right now
or not not great
yeah not great so the Apollo the the
Greek God or Roman anyone I think
mercury right Roman didn't know no he's
Greek and Roman yeah mercury yes thank
you so yes Greek Apollo was mentioned
twice that day so we did a small
blessing to Apollo giving him a blessing
of some sort we we said a chant I
believe actually I shouldn't say the
chant or it'll lose its power but that
kept her safe between here in New York
now did it work I don't I don't I don't
know but it was fun to do and
now a story we have so I'm pretty sure I
guess it another religion you're praying
one deity that you're praying to you've
you can spread it out almost in this way
yes I guess absolutely I I grew up under
the the with the veil of the the
Catholic Church in the background and
look love me my Catholics it just didn't
quite work for me so I lost religion at
a point and I've always envied it in in
everyone I meet that is relate it seeds
it just seems so say it seems so simple
and cool it just it like makes sense to
them and it's never made sense to me so
I didn't want something else to sort of
again occupy that space so I'm sort of
finding my own way of praying and being
faithful to a cause that I can um yeah I
can really I think there's something to
that man yeah I mean I open premiere
every day and I think by doing that
ritual I've made Dobby a real thing we
have create an entity that is Dobby
actually let's uh let me ask you guys a
question um because this is a fun
thought experiment I go down rabbit
holes all the time
Slenderman here's a concept right it got
created through the the average nature
of the Internet
yeah just chat rooms and people trying
to make false photos and trick other and
somehow this entity was formed and sure
that entity didn't exist until two girls
tried to kill someone or did they
successfully I think they I think there
was a murder that came of it and then
there was some other attempts but so now
now now we have to consider somebody in
the name of Slenderman I believe so
looking at I'm looking at
and physical actions were were were were
made based upon this fictional being so
I would argue Slenderman is real right
there is an entity that has caused
people to act is he physically real well
that would be fun wouldn't it was like
it's a night has gotten people to make
act if you guys want to just pause this
conversation real quick I can give you
the background on this stabbing occurred
on May 31st of 2014 in Waukesha
Wisconsin to 12 year old girls lured
their best friend into the woods and
stabbed her 19 times in an attempt to
prove the fictional character Slenderman
was in fact real the victim crawled to a
road where she was found she recovered
after six days in the hospital
must've been a short knife just bad the
perpetrators were found not guilty by
mental disease or defect and the slender
man's tendrils dig deeper I'm just done
do you what do you think about like is
Slenderman real in the ideas in in the
way that I just presented yeah yeah I
guess he was real and yeah kill or tried
to he's real that he is an ideology that
some people have adopted and now have I
mean you could argue that's really
everything yeah you can argue that it's
ever gone religion gets dude we got we
we got so midnight gospel in here no
nuts those girls
trying to kill for the name of
Slenderman than most religious people or
people it's like an actual accident it
was good was were they trying to slander
men supposed to come when you're killing
somebody what would they try I don't
think there was ever a dead like a years
old
and I back in the day did a Slenderman
short and there was no when we were
researching that there was no like main
plotline or thread with him is just a
bunch of people making up stuff other
people wanted lunderman there's yes kind
of Rosie Nico you've been silent to
staring at a bunch of just yeah just
reading about this stabbing man the
actual attack took place in nearby
forest during a game of hide-and-seek oh
there was pinned down and stabbed 19
times the arms legs and torso at the
kitchen knife or the 5-inch long blade
two wounds were two major organs one
missed a major artery of her heart by
less than a millimeter all Miller went
through her diaphragm cutting into her
liver and slowly while the victim to lay
down because the blood will come out
slower wire and gay guys are into a
leutner that they would get help but
instead simply left leutner dragged
herself to a nearby home was found by a
cyclist Greg Steinberg natural math of
the stabbing the creepypasta wiki was
blocked throughout the Waukesha School
District man Eric Knudsen said I am
deeply saddened by the tragedy in
Wisconsin my heart goes out the families
of those affected by terrible acts
basically those girls were committed to
mental institutions yeah free gnarly
stuff I mean not get out much to you
have a grasp on reality and probably
it's really shitty parents yeah it could
be so that could apply to anything knows
like if the Christian Church law said
and told started telling people that
your way to get into heaven is to murder
and kill people ya know it's not gonna
be well accepted but how many are gonna
do that how many people might start
making decisions based on what they're
sure I'm sure
well like I said I can look up on
Wikipedia the Crusades here
the history behind exactly what happened
yeah I like this quote from the police
chief
the stabbing should be a wake-up call
for all parents the internet is full of
information and wonderful sites that
teach entertain but that it can also be
full of dark and wicked things by the
fact that these girls wouldn't stab
somebody does that make the monster real
that is my question
I think there's at least a nugget in
there it's like through through somehow
it is now an entity in the zeitgeist
well I guess yeah there's this there's
this really good French miniseries
called Merion that's on Netflix I
believe check it out it deals with this
it's it's really cool dude I think you
guys would dig it it's very dark it's
all in French very quirky Niko I know
you'd like it because of the friend
connection it deals with this this
writer and I'm not gonna give much away
but she has created this based on her
true life events she's created this
character named Marianne who is a spirit
a vengeful witch spirit and she stops
writing this book series which has
become very very popular and when she
stops writing the series she starts
getting visions of the Spirit coming to
her telling her you have to write more
you have to write more on my story to
feed my power you need to feed my spirit
this this which has become addicted to
this the fame you know wow it's a really
cool story the way it plays up you guys
should I just added that to my list yeah
Mariana but it deals with that that idea
of like what power does the written word
and does notoriety and fame give to
these like abstract abstract maybe not
even you know I mean a lot of concepts
so a lot and you know there's in fact so
you know so the people in this podcast I
know that we have a short film I've been
working on called you monster which is I
summarized invests in this little quote
here the gaze of the audience drives
people to do bad things
it's true like people literally risk
their lives heck people kill themselves
kill themselves in front of people just
because they won't they need that gaze
of the audience it's really kind of
[ __ ] up think about it so that's what
this short film is about but it also
sounds like that's kind of the a
different twist on the metaphor for for
Merion which is what you're talking
about
almost as literally yeah I think it
something that people really should keep
in mind when they watch things like when
you when you go to watch a videos like
all these people are really shitty look
at this video they made like when you go
to watch your video you're giving them
power give people attention you're
giving them power you know whether even
if they're not getting ad revenue
quote-unquote like still going and
watching somebody's media and letting
them occupy your time and your energy
power like this yeah this kind of comes
back to my hermetic beliefs but you only
have like you have a lifetime of time
and every bit of like everything you
watch everything you pay attention to
everything you think about is taking a
chunk of that portion of time and giving
it the the energy out to that thing so
you you gotta watch out what you've put
in front of you you gotta watch out
where you start and it would say with
once you stare into the void it or the
abyss the abyss stares back yeah
staring out into the void was it
something like he used he used something
something monsters lest you become a
monster yourself should be careful he
thereby become a monster and abyss the
abyss will also gaze into thee yeah so
what do you guys think about so take
this a little bit further what you guys
think about all the serial killer things
that Netflix is been putting out was
like Ted Bundy in his own words and I'm
like yes you're making them stars as a
kid though cuz yeah it's like grow again
growing up I was always into that all
that side of the alt world there is that
weird I'm very attracted to a weird
stories right and and serial killers
have some of the weirdest and it's not
that you're proliferating the serial
killer or let's use Ted Bundy as an exam
it I think a lot of modern stuff and and
it depends on where you go and what you
watch what you plug into but um I think
it's just a fascination of seeing how
far people can go you're you're you're
able to someone you're able to connect
with moments and situations and really
start to see how scary people can be
through some of these stories and I
think one like Netflix does give you
stuff that a kind of pull some of the
punches or perhaps glorifies them yeah
that's that's extremely bad but I don't
think anyone very few people think Ted
Bundy's a cool guy right but you think
so he's a piece of [ __ ] but when you're
watching the minute to be showing like
boy this guy's charismatic I want to
watch him for a couple hours of my life
you know so they did a lot of jury yeah
there was a lot of like you know when
that Ted Bundy show was announced with
what's his name playing them everyone
was and it's just that sort of
idolization that is kind of weird man
like I I don't think it should be like
don't make that but it's it's the
nicknames it's cool names it's it's the
it's the publishing of the names in bold
on the front page of the paper you know
and that they censor look they
romanticize a lot of the kills because
when you actually start to read or like
when you actually start to dig in to
what what some of these serial killers
did it's very much stops being cool
quick it just goes like awful and leaves
you awake
it's it's almost like every every
statistic has like and he left 8 wounded
though each one of those wounded stories
is full just drive changing a bed that
just yeah and I think yeah a lot of
these a lot of these modern shows are
really just stepping over the atrocities
of the crime which is again
unfortunately a part of the
entertainment is the atrocity of the
crime that's why we talk about and so I
Jack the Ripper is infamous right yeah I
mean we do similar stuff like talk about
the same thing but with you know instead
of murders the tiger King right there's
no all he wanted was to get famous and
for people to watch him and to do this
thing and while he you know was doing
horrible things the animals everybody is
watching this network show yeah
should you be watching this Netflix show
does it glorify him in a way and put
funds even to his pocket for watching
this yeah sure sure oh yeah I mean
where's the where's the wait go like
sure I got some information and I'm more
informed about what's going on in that
animal abuse in that time in the country
but did I just give Joe Joe exotic eight
hours of my life by documentary bullets
like straight up does it become a moral
question like should you be watching
these things does he put them on that I
mean I think you can watch things in
watch up about this butts house phrase
like this that documentary it made Joe
exotic a charismatic character like it
didn't you know it's the shitty guy it
didn't go nearly as hard on him as it
could've and they took some of that
Carol basket and made her a villain and
once again like it's it's tough like cuz
you know and now having done like you
know worked on corridor for so long and
seen like corridor crew videos get made
like
moment it shows somebody like Carol
Baskin like smiling in slow motion over
somebody talking about how like how mean
she is and you know that like
immediately like my lights go off like
they're manipulating me like it's like
it's like the diss manipulating one on
one list editing 101 is like chill a
slow-motion shot of a person smiling
like hear somebody talking about how the
shitty they are and they look like an
[ __ ]
it's like when you were getting framed
for messing up the camera room and Sam's
talking about in your mind
yeah cut to you smiling in slow motion
and Sam's like I think there's something
it's like yeah the moment that starts
happening and edit I realize it I'm like
oh [ __ ] they're manipulating me and like
they didn't have material to do it
without having to fake it and now
suddenly it feels like it's false you
know yeah yeah I think there's an issue
with not everybody watches that and has
that light go off and be like Oh majora
I'm getting feeded as I'm feeding into
this even more yeah yeah dude reality
like reality TV gets away with that a
lot people know that it's set up based
on you would be so surprised how many
people think that all that drama all
that those relationships and those
fights are totally real it's like the
name reality TV is about the only thing
reality about that that makes it worse
because I feel like it translates and
ruins some of those reality stars in
real life because people go at them as
if that's that as if they know
everything and as if what they're
showing on the show is the real life and
so then they feel totally unable to go
what hacking on social media or whatever
as if these people are two-dimensional
as if they have one stand boy
yeah don't complicate it like it's I I
would love to know in a in a time where
we don't even print the names of killers
in the paper we don't do that stuff you
should be you should get a crappy
nickname I just saw a thing it was
really funny uh I forget on reddit what
post it was but it was like why do we
give serial killers cool names like why
can't we give them bad nicknames yeah
make them like like the Cowardly killer
like the I shat myself as I killed
myself in prison killer Oh
you know give them that no one wants to
aspire to not like the dark the dark red
killer the midnight strangler like come
on let's no it's a good point yeah but
that's like media you know they're
getting those clicks and getting those
views and exactly right they want you to
look at their reporting of it and they
want you to watch their thing and oh man
this news media gave them the best
serial killer nickname you could have
and now everybody knows who he is you
know there there have been studies done
I don't have the source on me but you
can look them up really easily most
shooters that have been involved in
shootings in in the like recent history
of our country have been once they
swooped through all their computers and
went through all their search history
they found that they were interested in
serial killers and I'm not talking about
serial killers exactly I'm specifically
talking about mass shooters mass
shooters the fetish of mass other mass
shooters that come for them because they
like the fame the whole point of instead
of like I could either kill myself and
never be heard about where I could shoot
a bunch of people and then be on a paper
and be talked about in beach chair you
know all over the news of course they're
gonna research these people
look up to them because that's the fan
they're trying to cheat that's what they
will not saying that if you're
interested in food crime shows and
serial killers then you're a killer no
but it's pretty interesting that that
that I guess marketing is what leads a
lot of these kids to maybe go more
extreme than if there wasn't that you
know pillar of excellence for a killer
that they could look at and be like I
want to sure the frighteners comes to
mind when Gary Busey's kid is like going
uh you know we're gonna have thirty
three I think Dahmer got thirty three or
you know yeah yeah sure sure
that's my fan club I have a term for
this Nick and I call it screaming into
the void because we're all we're all
temporary here you know what things past
the universe is cold and indifferent to
us so every screaming into the void in
different ways to try to like be
remembered and like when I see like
graffiti on the side of the bridge like
you know driving down the street it's
like that's screaming into the way
that's somebody trying to shout out like
this is my name like I just I'm just one
of the seven billion people on this
planet
I'm realistically insignificant right
here you could see the question for you
guys on that point I have a question for
all you guys how many generations back
do you know the names of your family
members what - like my great night it's
the ones I actually knew yeah yeah but
but beyond that you don't know who
they're you know where they what they
did there you go scream as much as you
want wait until the Hammers gets
destroyed by its own heat death I know
there's like you know there's a level to
it where you do test like laughs the
test of time or whatever I love like
Hispanic Mexican culture especially
where they really like dance there Emily
clothes and they really remember them
it's like part of I wish I really wish
Western culture could bring that in
I'd like a try but someone's like just
like really remembering your family and
appreciating you know for really though
as a Jew who came from a world war two
weird family thing
I guess I kind of like look at that like
oh you know your family like from like
generations back like I look at that
like that's really cool like to be able
to do that yeah yeah it's a we can
scream all we want
so this podcast summarize this is the
end of us screaming into the void now
upload this to the Internet we covered
such a multicolored universe of subjects
like wee-wee ping-pong to cross a mental
landscape that I can't quite grasp yeah
this is why we why we do the corridor
casts for interesting conversations like
this one I think we're at the end of our
broadcast time we're at the hour so yeah
you know I'm really glad that people are
tuning in to this thing and listening to
us by the way on the last podcast I
mentioned the site you know new corridor
digital comm streaming site that we're
building and a bunch of people gave us
awesome feedback some people signed up
for memberships which is super cool
thank you so much for doing that
yeah and you know there's more comin
we're still working on it and once again
like any and all comments on that you
know as people go and explore it and
share their experiences with it or he
even sign up for membership we super
super appreciate it though because we
are hard at work building that thing too
and you know Jake mentioned this but
like people like oh why are you doing
another streaming service when there's
already a bunch of streaming services
out there and it's like well first off
is $4 a month which is you know the
price of a coffee less than the price of
the coffee in these days so it's not
like you're paying $20 a month for this
thing but it's it's us trying to one
trying to value you the viewer more
compared to how they're valued on those
places like YouTube values your view at
one one-thousandth of a penny if that
whereas on our website we'd be valued a
lot more than that you
I think Jake put it put it simply where
it's like you'd have to you have to
watch a video four thousand times and
you equate your one monthly membership
fee on the site you know and it just
lets us do so much more with with the
audience that's there it's let's just go
ahead and create crazier content better
content all while having you know I
guess a core audience without having to
go out there and like please ten million
people just to make it happen you know
so then there's a lot of other things
going on to that that are good like for
example getting a little bit away from
having YouTube control our entire
business model and livelihoods I love
you too
don't get me wrong but you know which
would be perfect because like it's just
the perfect place for it where the core
audience is well you don't get to decide
with those corridor coins so if you guys
want us to make a difference yeah
imagine if you could take tell Netflix
where you want them to spend your
membership so that's the one thing that
we're gonna do differently than
everybody else out there
it's a streaming service but you
actually could just say as to what
productions your money goes towards so
court order comm check it out yeah yep
tomato right now pretty much a patrons
in our corridor cast people know about
it other than word of mouth yeah this is
a core audience here yeah yep alright
everybody thank you for listening to the
quarter cast I really appreciate it
we'll be back next week with another hip
conversation or we talk about who knows
Legos
oh no I really want to talk about the
guys who tried to week yeah dude that's
such a fascinating story
yeah I love it yeah dude we got to talk
about that that f1 series it's on
Netflix - outside of watching that so
good really well the thing is the first
season's good and the second season is
becoming a reality show and it's that's
pissing me off I mean it's just for the
first two episodes so we get better
about it all right guys good stuff
thanks for listening everybody we'll see
you in the next one bye guys